[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 y me acompaña en el estudio
rosa pérez más de euros a bienvenida
buena mañana de miércoles vamos a
iniciar revista de prensa en wyoming
tras las primarias republicanas en que
la crisis está dice chin y perdió frente
a la candidata al local por apoyada por
el ex presidente de donald trump
empezamos entonces con mayo mi tribu y
go exacta de buenos días raúl y lo
destacable hoy después de estas
elecciones primarias del partido
republicano también fueron del partido
demócrata dentro del estado de wyoming
pero como es un estado tradicionalmente
que manda a una republicano a la cámara
de representantes nos hacen tramos igual
que la prensa estadounidense en el
resultado de estas elecciones y por qué
por una cuestión en particular porque se
destaca la perdedora de estas primarias
en lugar de la ganadora y empecemos por
el nombre y sobre todo el apellido de
esta perdedora se trata de liz cheney
que como vemos es digamos la hija de
dick cheney uno de los llamados halcones
republicanos
y también en muchos años representante
de wyoming en el congreso de eeuu pero
también fue secretario de defensa bajo
la administración de bush padre y sobre
todo vicepresidente bajo la
administración de bush hijo bien liz
cheney su hija es representante en la
cámara de representantes para el estado
de wyoming desde 2017 y ahora dentro de
estas elecciones a primarias del partido
republicano se jugaba a poder revalidar
este mandato pero bien porque es
conocida y porque es una figura
destacada dentro del partido republicano
sobre todo por su oposición abierta y
declarada al ex presidente de donald
trump una oposición que se ha
materializado sobre todo a raíz de las
acusaciones que empezó a pronunciar a
donald trump tras las elecciones de 2020
que calificó de fraude electoral no bien
ahora vayamos después de este vídeo de
contexto a como titulan ya sabiendo todo
esto en los medios locales como bien
decías empezamos por el wyoming en
tribuna igual que dice hagemann gana a
cheney hija es la candidata apoyada por
donald trump no a quien donald trump ha
dado su apoyo públicamente y ella en un
primer momento nos dice la prensa del
estado de wyoming en que no se declaró
convencida del robo de las elecciones de
2020 pero finalmente ya acabó diciendo
que sí que fueron un fraude al final de
la campaña en temas de cifras halderman
la candidata de trampa insistimos obtuvo
113 mil votos mientras que cheney obtuvo
49 mil votos bien dentro del partido
demócrata
lynette raible competirá contra la
republicana para este único escaño en la
cámara de representantes por parte del
estado de wyoming por otro lado vamos a
citar una de las partes del discurso de
la ganadora dejando de halderman atrás a
su victoria tras que se conocieran estos
resultados y dice con nuestro voto de
hoy wyoming ha advertido a las élites ya
no vamos a tolerar representantes que no
nos representen wyoming ha dejado claro
que se acabó el gobierno del partido
único washington dice
demócratas y republicanos
a los que no les importa qué partido
está en el poder mientras ellos estén en
el poder y es que una de las cosas que
se ha criticado a cheney según a la
prensa local es que ella pasó gran parte
de su campaña sobre todo los últimos
meses en washington dice porque
recordemos sea y esto es una factor
determinante en su rol dentro del
partido es vicepresidenta del comité que
investiga el asalto a las del 6 de enero
el asalto al capitolio y precisamente
eso es una de las cosas que se le
reprochan encontramos dentro de la
prensa local varios votantes
republicanos que reprochan a cheney que
los haya utilizado y están en desacuerdo
con su oposición a trump bien y para
terminar con este medio una cita de
disseny y también tras conocer el
resultado dijo hace dos años gane esta
primaria con el 73% de los votos
fácilmente hoy podría haber hecho lo
mismo pero habría requerido que aceptara
la mentira del presidente trump sobre
las elecciones de 2020 vamos a orar con
el star tribune exacto que titula cheney
depuesta por hagerman la candidata
apoyada por trans un poco lo que
comentábamos y señalan que después del
segundo impeachment el expresidente
donald trump asumió la misión de
expulsar a la congresista liz cheney su
principal rival republicana y que el
martes lo logró así empieza este
artículo y dice ma que fue seguramente
la carrera al congreso más importante de
la historia de wyoming una de las más
financiadas y que muchos analistas lo
vieron como un referendo sobre la fuerza
que todavía tiene donald trump en el
partido viena ya para terminar también
un poco como la prensa local una cita de
luisen y dice desde el 6 de enero dije
que haré lo que sea necesario para
asegurar que donald trump nunca más se
acerque al despacho oval y habló en
serio y un poco esta incertidumbre sobre
cuáles van a ser los pasos ahora de esta
representante atrás ya es imposibilitar
no su reelección a la cámara de
representantes si va a lanzarse a la
carrera presidencial al en 2024 dentro
del partido republicano o no lo vamos a
analizar con nuestro primer invitado a
rosa muchísimas gracias por este
contexto esta previa digamos a lo que
vamos a analizar de lo que está pasando
políticamente en eeuu gracias rosa nos
vemos mañana con más empezamos a saludar
a nuestro primer invitado del día